matt harvey is famous in royals history
because in game five of the world series
he wanted to come back out for the ninth
inning the royals ended up winning the
game in the world series and now here he
is hud making his debut in a royals
uniform oh i'll tell you every player
should get the opportunity to wear a
royals uniform otto rips one into right
field that's a lead off single but he's
aboard and that'll bring up nick
castellanos castillanos takes a called
third strike on a late moving fastball
matt harvey welcome back the dark knight
one outrunner at first is fotto and
here's jesse winker
and another called third strike same
pitch fastball with late movement so he
strikes out castianos and winker look at
him he gave him a thumbs up never seen
that before saying yep that's a good
pitch right there two gone votto at
first and now eugenio suarez suarez
swings got it off the end and hits it to
left brett phillips is there to make the
catch side retired short good start for
matt harvey trevor bauer to the mound
for cincinnati trevor bauer pitched here
at kauffman stadium and when terry
francona
came to take him out of a game and the
royals are knocking him all over the
place bauer turned and fired a ball over
the wall in center field and slugger was
trying to get a throw from bauer
at the beginning of his outing as
opposed to at the end of his outing but
it didn't work his first pitch popped up
with merrifield first ball swinging hits
it a mile into the air out behind second
base and mike mustakas will go out give
way to nick castiano who comes in to
make the catch and whitmer field is out
one gone here in the first inning now
nikki lopez lopez bunts up the first
base line fato will field it goes for
the tag on lopez and applies the tag
lopez is out three unassisted two gone
point the royals coming out
and each of the first two hitters i mean
they are on the attack right now against
ballard here's the pitch to dozier he's
first ball swinging pops it up shallow
right castiano's in mustache out it's
costianos a very quick one two three
first it took four pitches for trevor
bauer our two out single brings jesse
winker to the play winker hits this one
high and deep to right field and it is
gone into the royals bullpen so jesse
winker who gave matt harvey a thumbs up
jumps on the first pitch that he sees
here in the third and cincinnati leads
two nothing that young man is stupid hot
he has 17 hits in his last 27 at bats
with six home runs now the batter suarez
this one lifted high and deep to center
field going back maryfield he's not
gonna get it that's gone hey eugenio
suarez with a solo shot and back-to-back
home runs here in the third and giving
the reds a three-nothing lead trevor
bauer to face brett phillips
fastball right down broadway strike
three so with 22 pitches bauer has set
down the first seven and now he gets
alberto mundesi wing and a miss just
flat blew him away the velocity keeps
creeping up for bauer two down so here's
viloria swinging a miss and that indeed
is the side being struck out for bauer
that's two walks of the inning and now
the tying run will come to the plate and
ryan o'hearn the payoff pitch swinging a
fly ball well hit to right but playable
castianos is there he's got it
and the inning is over nick castiano's
to begin thing this ball lifted into
left field and it is gone
oh my goodness castellanos destroyed it
and he made this now a four
nothing reds lead
royals are still without a hit the reds
were without a hit in game one until the
sixth inning brett phillips frank three
called fastball again
locks up
brett phillips and that's seven
strikeouts now for trevor bauer monday
is the hitter batting left-handed swing
and he lights it to right field over the
leaping bottle for a hit monday has the
royals first hit of the night here in
the fifth inning let's see if young
mabries gloria can do something at the
place swinging a miss and a strike out
of valoria and that takes care of the
royals eight strikeouts for bauer
through five kurt casalli the number
eight hitter their catcher here in game
two of this double header sally swings
and sucks one left field and deep
backing up the left fielder phillips he
turns looks it is gone and that
stretches the cincinnati lead to five to
nothing trevor bauer he has struck out
eight and he's only allowed one hit in
his five innings hunter dozier's the
batter he's over two and dozier swings
and sends the fly ball pretty well hit
to left playable the park holds it as
akiyama makes the catch well shy of the
track still just one hit allowed over
six shutout innings for trevor bauer not
sure what it is about these back end of
these seven inning double headers but
bauer is the master of it here in 2020.
strike three called back door breaking
ball froze o'hearn nine strikeouts for
trevor bauer this one driven into right
hervin has it and that'll do it
a one-hit complete game shutout for
trevor bauer and
olo
what we got here
we got descended shirt as he returns to
kansas city but this time he walks off
the field in much happier fashion